[Applause]
[Music]
i'm gonna ask you a question and it
doesn't count if you look it up on
wikipedia can you tell me what is the
currency of el salvador well the
official currency of el salvador is the
united states dollar that's right since
2001 the us dollar has been the legal
tender in el salvador
[Music]
however starting in september 2021 el
salvador will officially have two
currencies the us dollar and wait for it
bitcoin that's because el salvador has
just approved bitcoin as legal tender
and what does this mean exactly well you
can pay taxes in bitcoin and all
businesses are obliged to accept it as a
payment method
[Music]
and i know what many of you are thinking
particularly those of you who are fans
of cryptocurrencies viva el presidente
del salvador naib buchelli let's pack
our bags and go and live in this country
what's more if you're actually watching
this video from venezuela or argentina
it probably sounds divine because if
there's one problem common to many latin
american countries it is the currency
however el salvador is oblivious to
these problems why well precisely
because they use the dollar
so the burning question is what has
moved berkeley to declare bitcoin as
legal tender is el salvador really going
to become the paradise of
cryptocurrencies or is there some kind
of trojan horse lurking in the law with
which this decision will be implemented
today on visualpolitik we are going to
answer these questions the first let's
take a look at a bit of history
[Music]
insert bitcoin what is the main
difference between a cryptocurrency and
regular money normal money also called
fiat money is created by central banks
for example the u.s federal reserve or
the european central bank control the
money supply of dollars and euros
respectively bitcoin and most
cryptocurrencies are a totally different
story bitcoin was created in 2009 by
satoshi nakamoto a pseudonym that hides
the real identity of its creator we do
not even know who he is bitcoin is based
on blockchain technology so how does
this technology work well that's a topic
for another video the important point is
that bitcoin is a currency where there
is no need for commercial banks or
states to regulate it
and it's precisely this aspect that is
one of the most important things about
bitcoin it is not under any supervision
of any state or government that is there
is no one controlling the supply of
bitcoins theoretically there will also
be a limited number of bitcoins in the
world economy 21 million bitcoins when
that number is reached no more bitcoins
will be created and what is the
advantage of this well it prevents the
ruler of the day from manipulating the
money supply so this is supposed to give
stability to its value as a currency of
course this is the theory because the
reality is this
19th of may 2021 bitcoin whipsaws
investors with same-day plunge rally of
bloomberg the reality is that bitcoin
fluctuates more than russell crowe
scales so what does this mean well
almost nobody uses it as a payment
method but hold on a minute because it's
not just that its value is unusually
unstable something that is often not
mentioned is that bitcoin is also
remarkably slow take a look at these
comparisons between the transaction
processing capacity offered by visa the
credit card company and bitcoin
this means that in three hours visa has
the capability to process the same
transactions as bitcoin does in a year
bitcoin can certainly improve but the
reality is this so if you live in the
united states or the european union it
seems better to keep running on dollars
or euros and i know what you'll be
thinking seems like those guys on
visualpolitik are totally against
cryptocurrencies right well not exactly
in fact there is one place in the world
where cryptocurrencies may be of some
interest and we're talking about latin
america
to talk about hyperinflation is to talk
about latin america venezuela has
reached inflation rates of more than a
hundred thousand percent but it is not
the only country that has suffered
hyperinflation brazil and nicaragua had
cases of hyperinflation a few decades
ago let's not forget about argentina
check it out
19th of may 2021 inflation near 50 puts
argentina on paths that failed before
bloomberg so why does latin america have
so much hyperinflation the main reason
is that central banks manipulate the
currency at will to put it another way
they hit the money printing machine as
if there were no tomorrow this causes
their currencies to be worth less than
monopoly bills so the idea of using a
currency that is not controlled by any
government or central bank sounds like
music to the ears listen up
22nd of june 2021 as venezuela's economy
regresses crypto fills the gaps reuters
as you can imagine it is logical that in
venezuela they would use anything before
the bolivar and the question is why
would they want to use bitcoin in el
salvador after all in this country they
use the dollar as their official
currency in other words they don't have
huge hyper inflation problems so why
have they decided to gamble so much on
bitcoin well we're going to have a look
at that right now
kelly's big idea el salvador has a
millennial president naib buchelli is
the new rock star of latin american
politics although many think he's an
aspiring tyrant we talked about that in
more depth in another video that i'll
link for you down in the description but
the truth is in bakali's political plans
he didn't say anything about bitcoin
then suddenly in a conference about
bitcoin held in miami this video of
president vickelly was broadcast i will
send to congress a bill that will make
bitcoin a legal tender in el salvador in
the short term this will generate jobs
and help provide financial inclusion to
thousands outside the formal economy of
course after that there was no more talk
of anything else in el salvador
everything was up in the air because the
only official announcement was that
video in english that had been broadcast
in miami nobody explained anything in el
salvador and just three days later the
government presented the bitcoin law
which was approved in a matter of hours
by the parliament and we're talking
about a law that has 16 articles a
visual politics script takes up to four
times longer to write
[Music]
these 16 articles do not go into much
detail but there are some interesting
things for example it will be possible
to pay taxes with bitcoin and no
salvadorans will not be pioneers in this
because for months the swiss canton of
zuk has been accepting the payment of
taxes with bitcoin and ether even so it
is still striking but if there is only
one truly controversial point in the
bitcoin law it's article 7. take a look
every economic agent shall accept
bitcoin as a form of payment when so
offered by whoever acquires a goods or
service article 7 of the bitcoin act of
2021. according to this article it seems
clear that salvadorans will be forced to
accept bitcoin whether they want to or
not and at first this seemed to be
confirmed by president berkeley himself
if there was a lady who sells fruit in
the market she is obliged to receive
payment in bitcoin naib buchelli the
problem comes when once the bitcoin law
is approved you only start explaining
yourself two weeks later do you remember
the marx brothers and the contract scene
the party of the first part well kelly
has made a great tribute to them
8 is also interesting it says that
you'll be able to operate in bitcoin
with private wallets but that the state
will provide alternatives that allow
transactions in bitcoin so what does
this mean well basically that berkeley
has created a government wallet to
operate with bitcoins it will be called
the chivo and this is already starting
to clang a little because one of the
premises of cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin is that it is decentralized
something beyond the reach of
governments not to mention another issue
that does not inspire much confidence if
there is one thing that led to kelly to
sweep the elections it is that he
presented himself to the people as a
champion of transparency and the fight
against corruption a champion who would
allow them to forget the scandals of the
fmln governments however everything
about the chivo wallet is too
reminiscent of the bad practices of the
past
30th of june 2021 buchelli imitates fmln
and awards bitcoin projects directly el
salvador.com directly that is to say
without public tender bidding or
anything else but kelly has awarded the
development of the chivo wallet to a u.s
company called strike but hold on a
minute because the bitcoin law still
hides some catches after what we're
about to see it will be time for bitcoin
fans to answer the big question which is
whether you would really go to el
salvador and be able to live your daily
life using your favorite cryptocurrency
so keep watching
[Music]
the fine print of the bitcoin law do you
know what el salvador's main source of
income is remittances a quarter of
salvadorans some two million people live
abroad most of them in the united states
all these salvadorans send money back to
their families so how much money are we
talking about exactly well no less than
almost six billion dollars every year a
figure equivalent to 20 of el salvador's
gdp the country earns the same income
through this channel as it does through
exports salvadorans who have emigrated
using money orders to send these amounts
to their families we're talking about
companies like western union and
moneygram among others
[Music]
of course these companies do not provide
this service for free and charge
commissions the point according to
president mckelley is that salvador and
citizens will benefit if they use
bitcoin instead of dollars to make
remittances because it will be cheaper
so what's the problem basically that the
data keeps on saying the opposite
interestingly el salvador has one of the
lowest commissions for remittances in
the world to give you an idea the
average in latin america is 5.6
in el salvador it is 2.85
keep this number in mind 2.85 and how
much does it cost to change dollars to
bitcoin well the company that has the
most bitcoin atms in the country is
called athena this company charges a
commission of five percent
and you may be wondering so why is there
so much interest in bitcoin well here
comes a possible explanation the
government of el salvador has no control
over remittances it never knows how many
arrive nor can it tax them but then what
if the remittances arrived in bitcoin
imagine sending bitcoins to someone in
el salvador who has a chivo wallet that
wallet belongs to the government in
other words the government could place
whatever commission it wants to but i
know what you're thinking what if they
use a wallet other than the government
wallet and this is where the fine print
of the law comes in and things are not
so clear
21st of june 2021 el salvador funds to
change bitcoin to dollar would be
insufficient e i economista.net let's go
back to the bitcoin law it's article 14
says that the state will guarantee the
automatic and instantaneous
convertibility of bitcoin to dollars as
long as you use its wallet that is the
chivo wallet but wait a minute because
there's more here comes article 9 of the
law and what does that article say it
talks about limitations to automatic
conversion alternatives in other words
that the government can prohibit the use
of any wallet other than the government
wallet
[Music]
it is true these limitations are yet to
be fixed in a regulation and why would
they want to limit the wallets that are
used well the government has created a
fund of 150 million dollars to generate
the conversion of bitcoin to dollars the
problem is what would happen if everyone
rushed to convert bitcoin to dollars
what would happen if this fund ran out
well the truth is that nobody knows and
berkeley seems busy with other things
10th of june 2021 naid bucheli president
of el salvador gets laser eyes on
twitter to support bitcoin geraldo usa
buckelli has increased public spending
without raising taxes the country needs
dollars to pay off its debt these
dollars could come from remittances
while its citizens receive bitcoins the
choice for salvadorans is not easy
either in short if you do not use the
government wallet you will cop the risk
of having bitcoins because you already
know their volatility so from the outset
you have a very strong incentive to use
the government wallet
[Music]
and of course if you do not use this
wallet the chievo then you'll have to
pay attention to the regulations that
set the wallet limitations because once
the trust dollars are all gone there
could be a correlator situation in which
the exchange to dollars is limited in
other words the only thing you would
have left would be bitcoins with which
you will be able to operate in el
salvador but which will not be very
useful outside the country besides
remember that buchelli has another
urgent problem to solve
10th of march 2021 el salvador's debt
could reach 100 of its gdp according to
the ice swiss info the country's debt is
already more than 90 of gdp in other
words why wouldn't they just set a tax
to take advantage of remittances not to
mention that if salvadorans pay taxes
with bitcoins the dollar trust will be
converted into bitcoins all of a sudden
the salvadoran state will be in
possession of a lot of bitcoins with all
that this implies buckley's decision
could become a windfall if bitcoin is
revalued but the opposite could also
happen and the government could be
ruined if bitcoin sinks in that case the
big question is how el salvador will
then manage to deal with its foreign
debt i'm afraid that we will probably
end up talking about that topic in just
a few coming months but for now the
question is over to you do you think
that kelly's decision is a good one or
is it too risky would you like your
country to convert bitcoin into legal
tender as well you can leave me your
answers down in the comments in the
meantime don't forget that we release
new videos every week so subscribe to
this channel so you don't miss any of
our updates and if you liked this video
please give it a thumbs up and i'll see
you in the next one all the best see you
soon
[Music]
you